see this is where it began it's that
time again to talk to you about the
latest game releases and this week
lightning races against the clock to
save souls in lightning returns final
fantasy 13 the clock ticks down as you
traverse massive environments trying to
complete quest and when the clock stops
so does your game it's pretty harsh
life's not fair put it in your calendar
this one's out februari 11 if you feel
like ganging up on a bunch of monsters
this week check out toukiden age of the
demons coming to PSP and Vita what did
the monsters ever do to you oh they
destroyed your village well in that case
you can get into groups customize your
weapons armor and skills and slay those
demons or if you prefer you can purify
the monsters to obtain items I have
exorcise the demon start hunting
februari eleventh also this week you get
to blow [ __ ] up with World of Tanks
arriving on the xbox 360 players will
jump into their armoured vehicles
ranging from light tanks medium tanks
heavy tanks tank destroyers TVs and
self-propelled guns all fully capable to
send your enemies flying via Saddam gay
boys start the assault februari 12
in dangan ronpa trigger happy havoc
coming to Vita you get to test your
crime solving skills something strange
is happening at hopes Peak Academy a
remote-controlled bear is telling the
students to kill one another and not to
be identified as the killer observe the
crime scenes and interrogate the
classmates to learn the dark truth
discover the truth about professor
mustard in the candlestick februari 14
let's just sit back and enjoy the fact
that Metal Slug 3 is coming to PC this
week play online co-op with your friends
to use heavy machine guns and super
grenades to destroy wave after wave of
enemies and enjoy one of the best
run-and-gun video games since its debut
in 2000 if that's not enough to convince
you then how about these two words
ostrich slug
start saving POWs februari 14 also this
week Elly's back to kick some firefly
but in the last of us dlc left behind
the good news is she found her best
friend Riley bad news Riley's a firefly
but will their friendship survive the
different life choices these two girls
have made and the zombies and the game
comes out right in time for Valentine's
Day so you can spend it with the one you
love for your ps3 it's cheap date for
further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week 11 PST